yeah i feel like i've seen some youtube
videos with better cinematography than
some of the stuff out there in jade
brought in japan channels yeah 100 i'll
make chris's day
that'll make up for the lack of his
signature
yeah i mean i i hate [ __ ] on it so i
don't really know i don't really
understand
why i don't really know if they care i
don't really know if there's a want to
improve i
i just i just don't i just don't think
the audience is there no
i don't know the audience doesn't give a
[ __ ] well it's normal i mean
i mean the majority of the population he
was older so yeah generally i mean to be
fair i have seen a bunch of j
dramas where the cinematography is
absolute ass but i've still enjoyed it
because the story was just genuinely
really really good yeah and it wasn't
until like
it was like an afterthought of like oh
yeah that was a good j-drama
but the cinematography was [ __ ] i saw
this one and it was like
i think it was like a james bond show
and it was like
this japanese guy looked like japanese
george clooney it was really cool really
holy [ __ ] this guy's hot i think i know
who you're talking about actually
yeah he's kind of he looks kind of
western he looks western but he's but i
i looked it up and he's 100 japanese
yeah but he looks like george clooney if
he was japanese
i think i know who you're talking about
i don't know his name and he was just
like a no-nonsense attitude
guys like i'm coming to get the
information and just like beat this guy
up
but with just terrible lighting and
cinematography right
but it was like really i don't know why
i'm talking about this i was just
fascinated by him i was like that man so
goddamn hot good for him
i wish i was that because i've always
because i've had like the movie
experience of
wow this movie has [ __ ] fantastic
cinematography
yeah unfortunately the rest of the movie
is [ __ ]
yeah what was that what was that movie
it was a it was the
something still water or something where
it's like um
no no it was originally supposed to be
the bioshock movie but then they like
changed it halfway through
i have no idea yeah let me look it up
yeah i know exactly what it is but like
the movie had
like the most like amazing [ __ ]
cinematography it
looked [ __ ] incredible like it was
stylized perfectly
really creepy photography yeah look it
up um
yeah i mean i remember a cure for
wellness
i haven't seen that movie yeah that was
there wasn't that's a horror movie yeah
the horror movie
yeah for wellness that was apparently
that was originally supposed to be the
bioshock movie
and you can tell nothing like bioshock
yeah no obviously they like completely
changed the story
that threw me off when you said he's
meant to be the bioshock movie and his
supposedly was supposed to be the
bioshock movie but then something
happened with lee gal
d wise and they were like all right time
to rewrite the story completely but like
when you just look at the cinematography
and like the sets and stuff like that
i'm like okay i can kind of see what
they were going for
like this looks cool it's very stylized
cinematography is great
unfortunately the story was like what
like what the [ __ ] is happening nothing
makes sense characters were all [ __ ]
so like that's when i got to the point i
was like would i have preferred this
movie
if it had [ __ ] cinematography but a good
story versus
great cinematography but a shoot story
and this is like the animation versus
story debate that the anime fans go
through right like which do you prefer i
mean
if you had to choose story story story
but it has to be well acted
you know you can't tell me on a bad
story with not with
actors who don't sell the moment for you
right the room is pretty good
the room is pretty good i mean that's a
masterpiece that's
a unique exception but that's got
brilliant acting i don't know what
you're talking about
what a top grade actor tommy